hello guys I'm Ryan right this is really
say good name I'm eating a toss there
you go Ian Ian Izzie oh this man I
brought on the channel me from the
nursing home yeah it's not it's actually
a stand-up comedian who actually has
really enlightening comedy he has his
own channel really check it out there's
a lot oh he just started this like
really funny character satan's corner
yeah um bitey I got in like one minute
videos but yeah seriously they're worth
it I thought hey he's a comedian
neighbors - Seth Rogen in this back with
Zac Efron for some reason their friends
still oh it's going down all right okay
I'm not gonna lie to you didn't like the
kid now I do you know that from oh yeah
you know what won me over
what's a neighbor's yeah right we did
some stuff before watching this to get
in the mood I feel
and Selena Gomez she's so hot no what
are you doing we don't hit drinks in
here your parties must suck no we don't
throw parties here in the United States
sororities are not allowed to throw
parties in their own houses only brats
can you're sexist and a strict assistant
what our party that imported the way we
want to what's the name of our sorority
Kappa Avenue
do it do it right young ones usually
quiet
yeah oh [ __ ] somebody who can relate
stupid some people uh area neighbors
let's shut this [ __ ] down my theme song
dark money the mixing sweats everyone
you will focus like a mouse that's a
clown man I got an idea we go with the
air bag trick that's nothing work if it
works guys why want to work for girls
guys are idiot it's a little hard to
call cops without a phone
give us that back no it's dumbass
those girls are out of control Oishi so
I understand that there's no I
Lori there's two actually then actually
there's just one no that's a why don't
me no that's a no oh t hacker or kitty
do you silent I'll say that looks like a
delight I'll say that I think it looks
better than the first yeah hey dare I
say this one looks more solid in my
opinion you know like when I first heard
the plot I was like when I first heard
neighbors - yeah I was like I really
hope this thing something like a rehash
[ __ ] you know they're really taking it
in a different direction my make it is
for some reason I didn't think about
that even though it's called sorority
rising I was like I never thought of
sorority females like oh wow well that's
the death elements it makes women get
better it's just like all these bras
these hot girls and then Zac Efron it's
gonna get more people into Seth Rogen
teaming up nothing I want to see and I
don't know what that kid eats it just
looks like he just eats lettuce and just
raw meat I mean there's not an ounce of
fat on that kid he's like man I'm
beautiful
you comin he was can't he's so beautiful
scorch then you put him up against Seth
Rogen good contrast there Zac Efron's
like one of those guys that like I love
and um but on my private time I I hate
him cuz yeah he's like perfect
you're like he sees a good actor he's
funny he's ripped he's good looked like
and I don't even know where he came from
be honest I just like show though think
he's human
yeah he do showed up and it all suddenly
started shoving this kid and I'm just
like no no then I watched neighbors oh
my god you'd okay my books and then Seth
Rogen is just he's the most solid guy
maybe in like comedy history everybody
kind of does you do a couple of big hits
and it's going good and you made me
follow up with one or two more and then
it just falls off Rogen just like keeps
going man
it seems Ollie totally Rogan is like
II and he really worked hard to get to
worries that like he didn't just act you
wrote and I'm pretty sure he co-wrote
this one too with Evan Goldberg Nikolas
still out okay yeah there's a lot of
great writers on board for this my
relationship with Chloe grace Moretz um
it's been an interesting one let me make
sure I'm allowed to speak about this
let's hit girl yeah yeah 97 polish a 13
plus don't 518 she's 18 exactly mhm I
can get away with it the other way with
a congratulations I still feel creepy
now how do I properly say it's the same
thing with Selena Gomez when she was
like 15 16
you're like she's hot can't say she's
hot
I can't wait till she's 18 to say she's
just so you can say she's hot well or
then you're like you have like some
weird thing or like I think I got a
chance is that what you're thinking
you mean sometimes I my girls are like
maybe I can you know somehow manipulate
her you bump in at Starbucks yeah I know
what it's like to relate to a youth I
get where you're coming from
I'm older I'm more mature so I get it
you know I've been around the block yeah
exactly
yeah you know just or it's just not feel
bad when you masturbate to them who
ended when did you fall in love with her
was it Hit Girl
yeah oh boy yeah yeah she did not touch
myself I was 11 ok so last year after
February 10 which is just 12 right
yeah but [ __ ] man was she [ __ ]
Holford again edit you know and I think
they purposely like sexualized her on
that right there's a couple of shots I'm
like come on man this is 12 real girl in
[ __ ] uh she was in a letter let me in
just think about that um well she was in
that and she was like 14 or 15 and I was
like you're getting more attractive and
I can't say that about you I can't say
that about you now I can so it's okay
I'm not a pervert people sure yeah big
load up onto her Jess I can say that
it's really [ __ ] up I'm sorry if
cloggers for us happens to come across
this channel i told me he disrespect you
but you look great in a bikini being
yeah man I mean she's like really
talented too she did it she does yeah
bad too yeah she's actually super Kelly
yeah I forgot to mention that bad house
in via cuz she did a small part on 30
rock once man and she hurt I was oh yeah
yeah she crushed it a real career honey
oh yeah she killed it man and she kicked
she killed it in kick ass she kicked ass
and kick ass and that vampire movie I
was talking about she was great in that
she does a lot of great things that's
part of what adds to her her beauty wow
you know me I'm just serious I'm gonna I
have to end from the ATL southern girl
she's from Georgia
something tells me she'll be down for a
threesome you think so mmm I think
you're reading her all wrong I think
you're way up on that but I don't know
I'm reading something obviously
different than you all right all right
they got the right girls to be a part of
this I got Selena Gomez and Selena Gomez
is another one where I'm like same
situation with Chloe grace Moretz except
Hispanic can I tell you something Jonah
how old I am is that if you should be
picture and said this is Selena Gomez
and it wasn't I've been like oh she's
pretty like I just I don't know where I
know Selene I know I've heard the name a
million times I just don't know what I
know her from you know Wizards of
Waverly Place oh that will explain it
that was your demographic on the Disney
Channel at that time I don't Matt what
how you missed it kids are always like
mom I don't want to watch this no
wizards away really places on please
stop watch this now no Selena Gomez
she's really funny she's been trying to
break down into more serious roles and I
thought she was good at Spring Breakers
I'm really seeing other serious where
she's done but it's cool to see her like
she's she's in a league amongst
respected comedians in this movie you
know and hopefully she gets a chance to
shine because she was the lead of that
Disney show and she was really funny in
it I hope she gets the chance to be
known as you know like she's actually a
funny actress too
yeah the plot of this movie um I'm
enjoying it I mean it's gonna get guys
like me in the feet or more sure and
also uh guys like me that enjoy comedy
you like more the TNA I want the
laughing it's needed this you know it's
not because it's funny because of the
sexiness and the sexiness makes it funny
you know what I mean like it's a
give-and-take it's late
it actually it combines well as one
maybe that's that's what makes it really
interesting it's not like when you watch
a trailer for like now I haven't seen
the movie but dirty grandpa kind of
looks like that which my honor it has
that guy front where it's like yes hot
girls in bikinis it draws well it draws
but then there's comedy and then there's
hot girls in bikinis this seems like
part of the comedy is the fact that
there are hot girls in bikinis and I
like that because it also toys I hope it
does is I hope it kind of [ __ ] with
Seth Rogen where he like wants to party
with them and [ __ ] one out with them
well they like the nice thing too it
looks like it's just like it's kind of
based in reality and kind of not right
because like all these hot chicks is
just like these women are acting like
every every like college girl from the
80s comedies you know yeah where they're
just like I don't use frame yeah like I
got money everyone is like I don't think
that's ever happened so it's like it's
got that kind of angle to it too but I
really like you know things gonna be
awesome real fast like that's the cool
thing I love about Chloe grace Moretz
since she was a kid she's been doing
roles that probably people would
normally advise against her not Duke
sure hey you're gonna play Hit Girl your
12 year old kid and um you're gonna
murder people ridiculously and you're
gonna talk some nasty language and then
she does let me in which is she's
playing a vampire and then which is it
is violent at times now you got her here
and she's like smoking a joint in the
first clip we see her from and letting
loose and just wanting to party it's
cool to see an actress who's willing to
have fun like that I think Rose Byrne
does that - I was watching get him to
the Greek which is from the same
director of this movie I was like holy
crap that's Rose Byrne she's in this
movie I had
I completely forgot and her commitment
to comedy from neighbors and in that
movie and bridesmaids like she is
fantastic at comedy but she's also a
great dramatic actress and I feel like
Chloe grace Moretz has that same
capability with the right directors I
feel you 100%
so what million comedies is a thing it's
real it exists accept it yeah and none
of these days - how about it yeah you
know Tina found a bigwig they make
ghostbusters is with a female cast
there's a lot of funny woman out there
now dude there is man and it's nice to
see cuz everybody's kind of [ __ ] on my
mind like a there's not that many funny
women well I think like nowadays it's
pretty well proven that the you know
they're equaling up to the dudes these
days someone's gotta stop them well you
know look progression happens sometimes
Ryan and then you gotta kind of look at
that and say am I making the right call
in his nose now things shouldn't change
that's a that's a great point things
shouldn't change if we just have there's
a country from the way it was from the
beginning things would be in smooth
order you want to say those things
Hitler Hitler same kind of yeah same
they used to always in exact same things
that you just said so I don't know I
don't know Hitler is so I don't really
care what you're talking about but in
whatever it said is that how old I am
yeah even oh yeah there is well let me
tell you about this man named Hitler
okay you really want to get into this
let's talk in here your voice is gonna
change into semi Al Pacino when you get
open um God willing anyway guys listen
if you're new to the channel subscribe
today and become a reject it'll be worth
your time trust me Ian Gutowski has a
channel you can see some of his comedy
sketches podcasts funny guy you can also
catch him at you know performance stand
up usually pretty much every month right
yeah a couple times a week which is
mostly in Elena so yeah so hey checking
them out and you can follow me on vine
and Instagram I'm using them a lot
lately posting a lot of butthole
pictures awesome it's good I need to
really need to subscribe to that yeah
yeah follow me on Instagram I really
want to waste in the afternoon
oh dude cuz it's weird my butthole a
changes shape like it's I don't have to
put it it's like it's like a squid in a
way it's always rotating are you saying
it's got tentacles it's right if it
stops rotating that means something's
wrong weird stuff yeah